Aquí nos dan un sistema de ecuaciones y nos
piden resolver para "x" y "y".
Lo más fácil de hacer aquí, dado que en
ambas ecuaciones está la "y" ya despejada,
es considerar que bien, si "y" es igual a
esto y esta otra "y" es igual a esto otro,
entonces no queda de otra más que estas dos
expresiones sean iguales.
Esto es, si "y" es igual a esta expresión
que tenemos aquí y tengo que encontrar
"x" y "y" que cumplan con las dos ecuaciones,
¿por qué no sustituir entonces el valor de "y"
que conocemos de la primera ecuación
en esta segunda ecuación?
De tal manera que esta segunda ecuación,
se convierte en...
el lado izquierdo es --1/4 de "x" más 100
y esto es igual a...
a esto que tenemos aquí...
lo voy a poner en el mismo color...
-1/4 de "x" más 120, ahora, lo siguiente
que podemos hacer es llevar los términos
en "x" de un solo lado de la ecuación,
así es que para deshacernos
de este término en "x" del lado derecho,
lo más fácil es sumar
1/4 de "x" a ambos lados de la ecuación.
Hagamos eso, sumando entonces
1/4 de "x" del lado derecho
y sumamos 1/4 de "x" del lado derecho,
lo más seguro es que ya te diste cuenta
que algo muy extraño está sucediendo aquí.
Hacemos la suma -1/4 de "x" más 1/4 de "x"
es igual a 0, los términos en "x" se cancelan,
por lo cual solo nos queda 100 y esto es igual
a lo mismo, -1/4 de "x" más 1/4 de "x",
también es 0, por lo cual únicamente
nos queda del lado derecho 120.
Pero hemos obtenido entonces algo que sabemos
que no es posible, 100 no es igual a 120,
esto es una contradicción, al haber obtenido
esto sin sentido, podemos concluir entonces
que este sistema de ecuaciones no tiene solución...
sin solución...
Si hubiera alguna solución, estos dos números
tendrían que ser iguales,
sin embargo no son iguales.
Y si observamos con cuidado las ecuaciones
originales, se nos podría ocurrir porque
el sistema no tiene solución, estas dos rectas
o las rectas que estas ecuaciones representan
tiene exactamente la misma pendiente,
sin embargo, su ordenada al origen es diferente.
Si las graficáramos...
de hecho, vamos a hacer un bosquejo rápido aquí...
Aquí tenemos el eje "y", aquí tenemos el eje "x",
este es el eje "y", este es el eje "x",
esta primera recta tiene una ordenada
al origen de 100, podemos ubicarla aquí,
déjame ponerla un poco más abajo,
aquí está, una ordenada al origen de 100
y su pendiente es de -1/4...
podría verse algo como esto,
así se podría ver esta primera recta, la segunda recta que voy a graficar en rosa -1/4 de "x" más 120,
su ordenada al origen se ubicaría
aproximadamente ahí, en 120
y tiene la misma pendiente que la recta anterior, -1/4,
se vería más o menos así, las rectas son paralelas,
nunca se intersectan, no hay parejas de puntos "x"
y "y" que cumplan con las dos ecuaciones,
otra manera de considerar esto,
sería eliges una "x" arbitraria.
La multiplicas por -1/4, le sumas 100,
vas a obtener el valor de "y",
pero la ecuación de abajo establece que si al mismo valor de "x" lo multiplicas por -1/4 y le sumas 120,
vas a obtener el mismo valor de "Y".
Bien, pero eso puede ser verdad si 100 y 120
fueran el mismo número,
pero no son el mismo número, no es posible encontrar una solución del sistema,
estas dos rectas nunca se van a intersectar
pues tienen exactamente la misma pendiente.